okay our first speaker this morning is
abigail schreier
she's a graduate of columbia college and
went on to earn a bachelor of philosophy
degree from the university of oxford
and a jd from yale law school she's a
frequent contributor to the wall street
journal and she's the author of
irreversible damage
the transgender craze seducing our
daughters
it was named a best book by the
economist and the times of london
and she'll be drawing on themes from
that book in her talk today
in a recent essay on sub stack she wrote
about
big tech censorship of arguments that
question this
transgender craze in this particular
case
her subject was amazon.com sudden
removal
from its website of a book that is
critical
of the contemporary transgender movement
she argued that this kind of censorship
has the effect
of suppressing free speech both now and
in the future
as she wrote in her essay and i'm
quoting this is the chilling effect
of censorship that john milton called
the greatest
displeasure and indignity to a free and
knowing spirit that can be put upon him
she continued when censorship is imposed
by the government
we're the world's third largest
multinational
it forbids new life like a frost
while we at hillsdale happen to think
the right to free speech is essential
and so to our speaker i say welcome to
the spring thaw
abigail schreier
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much for that
very kind
introduction and thank you so much to
hillsdale for having me here today
so social conservatives are increasingly
asked to justify
why they have decided to target
transgender youth
as if they picked this issue because it
pulls well
or some other such nonsense let me make
it clear why this has suddenly become
my concern it is because in america
in 2007 had exactly one
gender clinic one anyone care to guess
how many we have now
three hundred so there are now
hundreds of pediatric gender clinics in
the u.s
planned parenthood gives out
testosterone on a first visit
depending on the state it absolutely
gives testosterone to minors
planned parenthood in oregon gives it to
15 year old girls
on their own recognizance they don't
even need a parental note
kaiser dispenses it so for today's teens
whether they have real or typical gender
dysphoria or not
testosterone is easily available double
mastectomy known as top surgery
is readily available no they do not
necessarily need parental approval
depending on the state and they
definitely don't need a therapist note
okay so let's let's talk about the
transgender phenomenon i'm going to
start by walking through
them the major issues and claims about
youth and adolescent transgender
transition
and we'll work our way to the big
question which is how did we get here
how did we get to a place in which we're
all supposed to pretend
that the only way you know that i'm a
woman is if i give you my pronouns
how did we get to an america in which a
15 year old in oregon
can begin a course of testosterone
without her parents permission
a lot of the answer of course comes from
the hard left but at least one part of
the answer
is conservative squeamishness about
issues we'd rather not deal with at all
so let's begin what by dealing with it
what is gender dysphoria gender
dysphoria
the severe discomfort in one's
biological sex
is absolutely real it's also exceedingly
rare
typically afflicting roughly 0.01
percent of the population
and overwhelmingly males so roughly one
in ten thousand males meaning nobody you
went to high school with
and it typically began in early
childhood ages two to four
little boys insisting no mommy i'm not a
boy i'm a girl
boys who were insistent consistent and
persistent in this feeling that they
were in the wrong body
it is by all accounts excruciating i've
talked to many
transgender adults most of them
biological males and they describe the
relentless chaff of a body
that feels all wrong now there are at
least three separate issues
i'm going to talk about today there are
the young kids
who have this this classic presentation
of gender dysphoria
some of whom the majority of whom would
have naturally outgrown it on their own
and historically did others became what
we used to call transsexual adults
there's number two there is the social
contagion currently spreading among
adolescent girls many of whom do not
have
typical gender dysphoria at all and
third
there are the activists and who have
already begun exploiting our confusion
and our sympathies in order to invade
women's protective spaces
and destroy women's sports they are all
very different
okay so the young kids now traditionally
as i said these were overwhelmingly
little boys
and if left alone meaning with no
intervention either to change their name
and pronouns what we now call social
transition
and no medical intervention over 70
percent of these kids
typically outgrew gender dysphoria on
their own
most would end up as gay men and some
would not some would
would not outgrow it and go on to be
called you know what we used to call
transsexuals
um and the these were not
these were not you know transsexuals
were not people who pre who used to
pretend
they were somehow really women or
were always truly female they were just
people who felt most comfortable
presenting as female
i've talked to a lot of transgender
adults and they'll tell you they know
that people can tell their biology is
different but their goal
isn't so much to fool other people as it
is to achieve
a level of comfort with themselves for
many that involves
hormonal intervention and surgeries and
i have talked to several who say
that hormones they took or the surgeries
they over they underwent
brought them a measure of peace i can
also tell you that they are generally
holding
down steady jobs and are leading good
productive lives
but today we don't just leave kids alone
who say this
and let chips fall where they may
letting some kids outgrow their gender
dysphoria and
others to transition when they reach
adulthood today we decide the moment a
child seems
not perfectly feminine or not perfectly
masculine
today we say i know what this is this is
a trans kid
we take them to a therapist or doctor
nearly all of whom
practice so-called affirmative care
that is nearly all of whom have accepted
that it is their job to immediately
affirm
or agree with the patient's
self-diagnosis
and to immediately help them medically
transition
teachers affirm young children in school
both by teaching the class that only
they
the children know their true genders
and encouraging kids to reintroduce
themselves to the class with their new
name and pronouns
therapists affirm and encourage minors
down this path
and even pediatricians do and the
typical next step for these kids
after changing their name and pronouns
to their friends and classmates
is puberty blockers puberty blockers
shut down the part of the pituitary that
directs the release of hormones
catalyzing
puberty the most common of these drugs
is called lupron
a drug that was originally used in the
chemical castration of sex offenders
to this day it has never been fda
approved
to halt healthy puberty
now you might ask why would any parent
or doctor do this
why would anyone stop the puberty in a
child
even a child with genuine gender
dysphoria
when that child would be highly likely
to outgrow the gender dysphoria if left
alone
some say because it's traumatizing to
let a child go through the puberty of
the sex
to which they don't wish to belong
the problem of this of course is that in
many cases puberty does seem to have
helped
children overcome their gender dysphoria
but there really is no satisfying answer
to why someone would do this given that
scientists have no way of predicting
which children will outgrow the
dysphoria of their on their own
and which won't but the argument that's
made is that these kids can't wait
the suicide rates of for the
trans-identified youth
and trans adults are very high the
argument goes
and so we need to get in there and start
fixing them as soon and dramatically as
possible
but unfortunately there are no long-term
studies
that indicate that puberty blockers cure
suicidality
or even that they produce better mental
health outcomes
there are not even good studies that
show they are safe for this population
long-term nor that they are reversible
there's a big debate right now in the
medical community about whether and to
what extent the effects of stopping
healthy puberty in adolescence is
reversible
if these kids later stop taking them
what we do know
is that puberty blockers will block all
the secondary sex characteristics
sexual maturation and development of
bone density from occurring
we do know that because of the
inhibition of bone density and other
risks
doctors don't like to keep a child on
puberty blockers for more than two years
and we know that once a child's healthy
puberty is arrested
placing her entirely out of step with
her peers
this seems to guarantee that she will
proceed to cross-sex hormones like
testosterone
in studies nearly 100 of kids who are
put on puberty blockers
proceed to cross-sex hormones
and we know that if a child goes from
puberty blockers to cross-sex hormones
that child will be infertile
she may also have permanent sexual
dysfunction given that her sex organs
never reached adult maturity
but she will certainly be infertile
so the claim that puberty blockers are
safe and reversible
for this population is not well founded
and the claim that it's a neutral
intervention just a pause button they
say
without serious downsides is simply
false
we wouldn't accept this level of glib
salesmanship
in any other area of medicine
okay so those are the kids who actually
have gender dysphoria
for the nearly 100 year history
of diagnosing gender dysphoria these
little kids were what we were talking
about when we
when we talked about gender dysphoria
but in the last decade
that thanks in large part to social
media
there's been another population that
claims to have gender dysphoria
this is a population that never before
had gender dysphoria in
any significant numbers in fact before
2007
there was no extant scientific
literature on their having gender
dysphoria at all
teenage girls this is the phenomenon
brown university public health
researcher dr
lisa littman called rapid onset gender
dysphoria
and it's and it refers to a sudden spike
in transgender identification
among teen girls with no childhood
history of gender dysphoria at all
not only have the rates of these girls
claiming trans identification
risen dramatically in the us and all
across the west
over four thousand four hundred percent
rise
in teen girls presenting for gender
treatment at the uk's national gender
clinic for instance
but teenage girls are now the leading
demographic
of those claiming to have gender
dysphoria
what's going on the answer
is social contagion one more
instance of teen girls sharing and
spreading
their pain there's a long history of
pure contagion with this demographic of
course we know that
anorexia and bulimia spread this way
and we know that this demographic teen
girls is in the midst
of the worst mental health crisis on
record
with the highest rates of anxiety
self-harm
and clinical depression we've ever seen
we know that this pop the population who
tends to fall
into social contagions is the same high
anxiety depressive group of girls
who struggle socially in adolescence and
tend to hate their bodies
add to that a school environment where
you can achieve immediate
valorization and popularity by declaring
a trans identity
and of course the delicious temptation
to stick it to mom
add further the great many trans social
media influencers
who can't wait to convince troubled teen
girls
that identifying as trans and starting a
course of testosterone
will cure all of their problems
and you have a very fast spreading
social phenomenon
i've spoken to families at top girls
schools that will
attest that 15 or 20 percent or in some
one case
30 percent of the girls in their
daughter's 7th grade class
now identify as trans
when you see that you're witnessing a
social contagion in action
there is no other reasonable explanation
these teen girls are in a great deal of
very
real pain almost all of them have dealt
at some point with an eating disorder
or engaged in cutting or have been
diagnosed with
other serious mental health
comorbidities
and now they're being allowed to
self-diagnose with gender dysphoria
by a medical establishment that's
decided its job
is merely to affirm and agree with these
girls
a medical establishment that has with
regard to trans-identified adolescents
effectively turned its doctors into life
coaches
since my book irreversible damage was
published in june of 2020
more evidence than i ever could have
imagined has come out
indicating that this thesis is correct
you may not know the name kira bell this
is a young woman in the uk
very troubled in adolescence who was
rushed to transition in her teen years
and came to regret it she underwent
double mastectomy
and spent years on testosterone only to
realize that her problem
had never been gender she sued the
national gender clinic in england
and back in december the high court of
justice examined her case
and the claim of similarly situated
plaintiffs
and she won the court examined the
medical protocols applied to her
protocols identical to the ones we have
in america
and the high court of justice was
horrified
it was absolutely appalled that a young
girl
had been allowed to consent to
eliminating her future fertility
and sexual function at an age when she
could not have possibly
gauged that loss she had begun
transitioning at 15.
this case was called a landmark case in
england it was covered by the times of
london
the economist and even the guardian
it was a it was seen as a real
condemnation
of the effort to fast track so many
young girls to transition
and one of the things the court noted
was that the clinic
had been unable to show any
psychological improvement
in the girls that had treated with
transitioning hormones
if you didn't read about the landmark
kiribel case in the american legacy
media
well that's because they decided to
pretend it didn't happen
just as they continue to ignore or
dismiss the stories of the
thousands of d transitioners these are
young women who
underwent medical transition and later
regretted it and attempt to reverse
course
a lot of these treatments are permanent
but but
they they do what they can to try to
reverse some of the effects
so in america the teen trans phenomenon
gets treated
as a conservative issue that is a
political issue
rather than a medical one and so perhaps
the greatest medical scandal
of this decade is dismissed as a
conservative preoccupation
finally there's a third group we of
people we talk about when we talk about
the transgender phenomenon
and this is the group that seems to want
to eradicate girls and women's sports
and protective spaces
many or most of these proponents are not
transgender themselves
but they are activist and they are
energized
and they do seem to be winning they
promote dangerous bills like the
equality act now before the u.s senate
which would make it impossible ever to
distinguish
betw between biological men and women
ever to exclude a biological male from a
girl's sports team
or scholarship or a woman's protective
space like locker rooms and prisons
and they would do this based entirely on
a male's
self-identification all that a violent
male felon needs to do
is announce his new pronouns and
identity
and he becomes eligible to transfer into
women's prison
wherever such laws are found we have
these now
laws now in california and the state of
washington
and as you might imagine hundreds of
biological male prisoners
have already applied to transfer in
for this third group it is not enough
that we create a separate unisex
bathroom
while preserving a women's room for
women it is not
enough to have an open category for
those trans identified athletes
who do not wish to be stigmatized while
preserving the girls team for biological
girls
and it is not enough to keep a separate
safe zone in a prison for those trans
trans-identified biological men
who might be at risk in male prison no
they are working to abolish all women's
only spaces
they want all men to be able to
self-identify their way
into them and they want to do it right
now
so these three groups are very different
you have the young children
some of whom do suffer with gender
dysphoria you have the adolescent girls
most of whom are caught in a social
contagion and you have the activists
who are using the other two groups to
attack women and to advance their goal
of chaos and social upheaval
what these three have in common has
nothing to do with real gender dysphoria
what they have in common is that they
are all shrouded in gender ideology
put another way what they have in common
is that they are
all soaked in lies
lies are told about the risks of the
treatments we administer to young
children
both to play down the very real dangers
and to wildly exaggerate
to the degree to which we know medical
transition to be a cure
lies are told about the researchers and
journalists who try to report on the
social contagion
among teen girls in order to discredit
that hypothesis
or to stifle its revelation lies are
told
both about the inherent dangers of
eradicating women's protective spaces
and rights and the degree and to
exaggerate the degree to which
this is the only way to save a community
from suicide the way to think about
gender ideology
is that it is a sibling of critical race
theory
critical race theory goes into schools
to convince white kids
that they bear the original sin of their
skin color
gender ideology marches into those same
schools and tells
kindergarteners yes they do this
throughout the public school system in
california
beginning in kindergarten to tell
preschool children
that there are a great many genders and
while someone may have guessed
at birth that you were a boy or a girl
only you
know your true gender
critical race theory postulates that
race is the most important feature
of any person and that white people
existing as they do
in a state of racial privilege are not
able to participate
in a wide variety of discussions about
our democracy
gender ideology tells women which it
calls cis women
that they are not entitled to their fear
or their sense of unfairness
as biological men invade their
protective spaces
and claim their trophies and records and
scholarships
in fact women and girls can't even use
the english language to describe their
problem
since calling a trans woman biological
male
is an act of transphobic bigotry
both of these invidious mendacious
dogmas
have corrupted our schools our
universities
almost all of our legacy newspapers and
magazines
the medical accrediting organizations
american academy of pediatrics american
medical association american psychiatric
association
pediatric endocrine society and even our
scientific journals
just to give you a sense of how far
things have gone
about eight months ago i was contacted
by a member of the national association
of science writers
the nasw is an association of
journalists
with scientific backgrounds tasked with
explaining scientific
phenomena to the public and the member
of the
nasw who contacted me wanted me to know
that a member of the online forum
had been expelled from mentioning my
book
i contacted the member who had been
the the person who mentioned my book who
had been expelled
sean scott and he told me he hadn't even
read my book
it just sounded interesting to him
he was immediately banned from the forum
and labeled transphobic
i've heard the same thing from
endocrinologists and psychiatrists
and pediatricians and scientific
researchers who write around these
issues
if they point out the risks of gender
interventions
they struggle to get their research into
journals and very often their letters to
the editor
pointing out flaws and studies touting
all these interventions
those letters aren't published the
funding goes to research that promotes
gender transition
and downplays the risks there are
phalanxes of young doctors now
many of them in pediatrics or child
psychiatry
who believe their primary job is social
justice
and they don't hide this they brag about
it online every day
and you're starting to see this kind of
thing put into practice
perhaps america's most prestigious
hospital brigham
and women's hospital in boston recently
announced that it would offer
preferential care
to patients based on race
and on questions of gender we're seeing
it with a mass celebration of
transitioning treatments
provided to young people by doctors who
show
an inexcusable complacency about the
risks of these treatments
the washington post just last week
quoted some of these young doctors
and claimed that it was a factual matter
that puberty blockers
are fully reversible that was the quote
puberty backers are fully reversible
it's except that that's not someone any
something anyone can claim to know yet
they're certainly not psychologically
reversible and they may not
be physically reversible either we
simply don't have the data yet
so you're seeing the startlingly quick
corruption
of medicine and science and it's a
symptom of a larger
woke corruption of american society
now there's something i say every time i
am asked to speak and i say this for the
simple reason that it
is true transgender adults are some of
the nicest
soberest and kindest people i have met
in my work as a journalist
they have good jobs they have stable
associations
and they are leading admirable and
productive lives
they have absolutely no desire to harm
women or to push
transition on mass and children the
activists do not
represent them i have met adult
transgender people
who seem to have been helped by
transition
but also a belief in freedom absolutely
requires
allowing adults to make really
consequential decisions
about their lives whether it's
adulthood in a free society means that
you can change your religion
you can change your name you can take a
dangerous
job such as andy noe and i have
and yes you can choose to undergo sex
reassignment surgery
and whenever i am asked in com i am in
conversation with a transgender adult i
always use
their chosen name and pronouns and i
believe it
speaks well of conservatives who extend
this courtesy
but and this is a big but
i never lie
so i will never say and will never say
trans women are women this is a
dangerous lie
it's a lie which when promoted in public
leads to unjust and even dangerous
consequences for women and girls
when we lie in public we usher in all
kinds of consequences
the obliteration of women's protective
spaces and the destruction of women's
and girls athletics
rejecting lies sorry parroting these
lies
is not mere courtesy whatever proponents
say
it's the cowardly surrender of women's
welfare
as a sacrifice to the woke gods
and it's wrong in the public sphere
the lie is the harm it does damage to
our ability to communicate
to comprehend each other and it makes it
impossible to object
in the face of unfairness and cruelty
if quote a trans girl really is just a
kind of girl
after all there is no basis for
objecting
to a 17 year old boy who handily beat
all the girls on the track team
now i'm often asked why are the trans
activists
doing this why would a teacher tell her
class of kindergartners
that only they know their true gender
what could possibly be the justification
for telling small boys that they might
really be girls
and telling small girls that they might
really be boys
the biggest hint i got to the answer
came from talking to d transitioners
remember these are young women who
underwent transition and then
later regretted it
again and again they told me that while
they were transitioning
they were angry they were sullen
and they were politically radical
they very often cut off their families
they were coached in this by transgender
influencers online
and they rush toward their new glitter
families
you'll often see gender confused people
among the ranks of antifa
or at black lives matter rallies having
turned against their families of origin
they are easy prey for those who recruit
revolutionaries
put another way the chaos is
the point just as the point of critical
race theory
is to turn the american people against
one another
so the point of gender ideology is to
stop the formation of stable families
the building blocks of american life
let me say this again this is not the
goal of all transgender adults
but it is the goal of gender ideology
and the transgender movement namely the
creation of a new victim class
eager to join the revolution
so what do we do about this how do we
push back
on the onslaught of gender ideology
first we must oppose the indoctrination
of children
in general ideology there is absolutely
no good reason for it
and it does very real harm you can
absolutely insist that all tree
children treat each other kindly without
indoctrinating an entire
generation in gender confusion
second in public we must speak up and we
must speak the truth
always wherever we find ourselves at
work whatever we do
we must refuse to recite the lies
if conservatives are to confront these
issues we know we must know something
about them
we must overcome our squeamishness
we must clearly distinguish for instance
between transgender americans
many of whom are wonderful and an
ideological movement
which seeks to warp our children and
wreck our families
this is a movement that would turn our
children against themselves
because its advocates know there is no
greater harm
there is no greater horror to a parent
there is no quicker way to bring america
to its knees than by prompting our
children
to do irreversible damage to themselves
the people who've been pushing this
ideology they got a big head start on us
perhaps by a decade but they have
awakened a sleeping giant
the success of my book the fact that i
was invited to speak to you today
and the state legislators that are now
debating these issues
testify that a cultural battle is at
last being fought
we cannot afford to lose these are our
kids and grandkids
our future literally depends on our
winningness
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is the first audience i've been to
that didn't want to throw things at me
okay thank you miss tryer we now have
time for a few questions
if you would like to ask a question
please come make your way to a
microphone
yes abigail
couple things number one caitlyn jenner
couple questions one have you ever met
her number two
would you vote for her at this point if
you were a california resident
and number three if she were to become
governor of california
how would how would this movement change
okay so i i would have you know
i i don't know very much about her
politics
i really don't except that she's
republican and supported trump
um i don't have any problem with
electing someone like caitlyn jenner
um i i i will tell you that
the um she has certainly pushed back on
on some of the activists
and she has said that transitioning was
easier than coming out and supporting
trump
um uh
that's i just don't see that as a threat
her or you know as far as i know her and
i don't
you know have great knowledge of her
politically
i'm not sure anyone does but i don't see
someone like her
as a threat um now that doesn't mean
that um someone who has a
history of of encouraging puberty
blockers on children
isn't a problem the biggest threat we're
facing in america right now
is and elizabeth warren i think a week
ago said that it's transitioning care
you know
they call it gender affirming care this
is another lie gender affirming it's
only
affirming your gender that's all we're
doing
is a is a right a human right of
children
elizabeth warren said that the moment it
becomes a human right
every parent who disagrees with it
has to worry about their custody
this is coming here it's already all
over in canada
this is coming here it will absolutely
threaten parents custody rights if they
don't go along with it and when i tell
you the parents who call me
are politically progressive the ones who
have lost their daughters to this
supported gay marriage long before it
was legal
they do not have any issue with gay
people they do not have any issue with
gay rights they do not have any issue
with transgender rights
they simply didn't think it was right
for their daughter
they thought she had other mental health
problems and that's an issue for social
workers and therapists
they were undermined by their teachers
they were undermined by the therapist
they paid for
they were undermined by by their doctors
everyone affirmed the kid
against the parents wishes
question to the speakers left thank you
so much for coming i really appreciate
you being here i'm a retired
neurosurgeon and i have been
combing through all the medical
literature and it's been shocking to me
to see on
just about every medical topic that this
social justice infiltration has taken
place
um that the racial
justice issues are also taking place in
that with
our latest plague uh the science is not
science
okay this is not valid scientific method
for
any of this and it mortifies me okay
but also there has to be more behind it
granted you've got your cultural and
social and political issues
but are you following the money
who's profiting from this and and that
will
answer a lot of other questions and
frankly you know this is more than just
a cultural war it's a spiritual one
and this is the epitome of darkness
thank you
should i respond okay so um sorry
um like i said i'm not used to friendly
audiences i uh
sorry um okay so
that's that's right i mean there there
is a political um
there is a question of the the funding
um i don't personally
you know there are journalists who have
done work to tr trace the funding
i i actually look at the culture i mean
that's what i do as a journalist
i look at cultural phenomena and the
reason part of the reason is
um well i do it because that
is what interests me i mean that's the
truth but i will say this
conservatives are really good at
understanding things in terms of
politics
what we're not so great at is fighting
cultural battles
one might say we're pretty bad at it
because we see an issue like this and we
kind of say uh
that has nothing to do with me um yeah
actually it has everything to do with
everyone in this room
um it's being pushed so aggressively in
the public school systems
that there are i i was able to in my
book i talk about my investigation into
the california public school system
and what i found was that there was no
distinction between the activists and
the public school teachers
the activists are literally training the
teachers
oh there you go thank you so much for
being here you've
written such an important book i i
actually discovered you
um on the interview that you did with
jordan peterson
which i would welcome everybody to check
out on online um
i guess i just wanted to expand on the
previous question
i have a lot of doctors in my family and
haven't really gotten any satisfaction
when i've tried to talk with them
with regard to the hippocratic oath and
and the doctors that you spoke with i
mean
how how did they reconcile um
performing these surgeries and you know
hormone treatments
with with that that oat so i talk about
this a lot in my book cause i
interviewed some of the surgeons who
performed these surgeries
and um um
and so anyway i talked to them in my you
know i i go through that a little bit
but
but one of the things i will say is you
know this
really is an an ideology and when it
captures
people there's a remarkable in curiosity
about basic science so for instance
they will say to me but they they're so
happy when they they seem very pleased
i'm saving lives
they they believe that now the
the doctor dr lisa lipman who did the
original study on this
one of the things that alarmed her and i
talk about my book is that
when she attended a wpath conference
that's a
medical conference for transgender
health it was the old transgender health
society
what she couldn't believe is that when
they would discover this was her first
she she's an obgyn gyn by by
um you know that was her first residency
and whatnot and this was her first w
path conference and i think 2017 she
attended
and what she discovered was that it was
the only medical conference she had ever
attended this woman is a politically
progressive
um where no one was discussing the risks
it was a celebration only zone and in
fact they would then
go on to de-platform speakers now these
were
experts in gender dysphoria like ken
zucker these are not
right wingers but if they were willing
to talk about risks
or any course of treatment other than
immediate transition
they were canceled
question to the speakers left
thank you kindly for coming and
addressing us phenomenal talk
and awesome that you talked about the
how at the end you mentioned the why
to create chaos i guess i would submit
it's a little deeper than that i would
think that it's just pure
evil and i guess my question to you
would be
do you think that this is one of the
roads to
what a lot of progressives uber
billionaires talking about depopulation
of our planet when you mentioned that
what 30 percent
go on to do the testosterone and then
are infertile
you know um
it's hard for me to assign motivation
without evidence
you know so i you know unless i
i would never make a claim like that
unless i had proof that this was part of
an effort to depopulate the planet
um you know if there was evidence i
would certainly look at it but
but i think you know the way to
understand it is really
to look at other radical left movements
um because they they seem very sim
similar they seem to be
creating chaos in the population because
that's
how because if you have total chaos and
overhaul
then what you want is redemption through
this new political order
um so that that seems to be what they're
priming everyone for
but but again you know not not everyone
needs to you know who promotes this
needs to be totally aware of that but
they're participating in an ideological
movement that seems to be headed that
way
question to the speakers right hi thank
you so much for your book i have
uh two children a son who is 15 and a
daughter who's 17.
they've gone they went to a very small
middle school in northern california
we know five girls in that school that
are transitioning one of them is my
son's closest girlfriend and she's
becoming tyler and her parents went
through a really messy divorce right and
she's politically very radical
but i just another mom just i just spoke
with
her 10 year old daughter came home
saying
i'm binary pansexual and i'm identifying
as a boy now
i don't know what to say to her like i
just need some practical advice like
what should i
say to this mother well you know a
couple of things i mean i i think the
book is helpful because
the book my book doesn't exactly tell
you i mean it gives you some suggestions
but it really isn't about what to do
it's more about how to understand this
but to all of you i would say
the moment you hear that get your kids
out of that school
i have talked to parents who have lost
their kids to this
they push it very hard at many
universities
and i can tell you how much less they
care about that ivy league sticker
after their kid is now on hormone
treatments
because this happens over and over is
completely covered by every ivy league
school
you can start school and in some cases
they ended without their breasts
it absolutely happens
i guess that's an advertisement for
hillsdale yeah
[Applause]
question to the speakers left
i just wanted to make a couple of
comments uh uh
years ago i spent some time in sweden uh
with the military
and one of the things i learned about
sweden was
through the people i was working with
where they said the state
owns your children
and i said what do you mean by that they
said we bring them up
we feed them we put clothes on them but
we do not own them the state can come in
any time they care to and remove them
from your
family for any reason
well that started me thinking about it
and over the years i discovered that the
marxist
lifestyle is to break down the family
any way they can and once they take over
they can change things
to fit their situation
they want to create chaos like you were
saying in your book
this is all a useful distraction for
something else
that you're talking about it's just one
out of many
distractions so
the type of politics that we're heading
toward
will be as you said
the way the left works this is not their
real agenda
their real agenda is control over every
living thing
to the speakers right thank you thank
you abigail for being here that was a
nice tee up really just to a comment to
say thank you
for helping this audience connect the
dots between your work and the broader
theme of critical race theory
i think mark stein touched on this a
little bit last night around the
language
of crt and understanding what it is and
us taking control back
of our language that's really really
important and i think andy will probably
touch on this
around his work because it is all
fabulously and destructively
connected so thank you for your work in
helping us connect the dots
thank you
question to the speakers left
i'm sure my wife is asking herself what
are you
doing bill uh but first of all
i want to salute you and thank you for
your courage
[Music]
[Applause]
you have done a wonderful job of
presenting things that
for me personally were always sort of
lying under the surface
um and i guess i'm
to the point that i'm just tired of
sitting and saying and doing nothing
about it
and i keep asking you you've you've
given a lot of
reasons and
justifications for what these people are
doing
with and to our country and but i keep
coming back to the question of why
and who and
i guess i'm left with the conclusion of
where are the roots of this and
dare i say satan
there's there just seems to be no
no real justifiable reason for what's
happening in america today
thank you very much
question to the speakers right hey thank
you i um
oh i can't hold it okay um i was
wondering if you could clarify something
i might have misunderstood earlier and
then also have a question based off of
that
you were talking about infertility and i
couldn't tell if it was caused by the
beta blockers themselves or the fact
that they
move on to testosterone okay so that's a
really good question
puberty blocker going from puberty
blockers so
blocked puberty straight to cross-sex
hormones
guarant virtually guarantees infertility
starting with the course of testosterone
most of the kids who
you know many of the kids who are
discover this in their teen years
they've already been through puberty so
they go straight to testosterone
and that puts fertility at very serious
risk for various reasons but it's not
the guarantee that going from puberty
blockers to testosterone is
but puberty blockers themselves do those
cause and fertility
is more what comes afterwards well you
can't you can't um have a baby if you
haven't gone through puberty so of
course you you don't you aren't fertile
while you
haven't even been through puberty and
then if
if the puberty blockers if you go off
the puberty backers
um there is a chance you know
you may you may just revert to normal
we don't really have the data yet to
know because we haven't been
experimenting on these kids for long
enough
um so i mean that's it is experimental
treatment that's what we're doing we're
conducting a mass experiment
so traditionally puberty blockers were
used
um in very in many different ways but
one of the ways was
there's a condition called precocious
puberty
and that is when a four-year-old starts
developing breasts
so you we we shut off an overactive
pituitary essentially or we pause it
that was the idea it was a pause button
and then you could really we could un we
could take the kid off of it
you know around the time it would be
normal and healthy to go through puberty
and let
and at that point puberty seemed to take
its course without
problem the the problem is we're putting
we're now putting
we're putting puberty blockers into a
different population these are kids
who are going through healthy normal
puberty and we're arresting that
and and i've been told by many doctors
this is not my own research but many
doctors
when you arrest a healthy system when
you shut down a healthy system that's
operating properly
properly in the endocrine system there's
just no guarantee
that it's going to pick up where it was
supposed to if you go off them
now again we don't have the research yet
to know one way or the other
thank you a lot more sense so i guess i
guess my question is um
it sounds like we're seeing that the
current social trend is creating like a
hyperinflation of people who are
or children who are uh have gender
dysphoria
is it possible that before now
there was it kind of skewed lower than
it actually was
due to it being uh a lot harder to come
out right
dysphoric and have you ever seen a
children named or a child in the
instance where
if we found that puberty blockers were
potentially healthy
where they could have the case to
actually benefit from it
sure so are there these kids who are
absolutely have gender dysphoria and
might be helped by puberty blockers yes
it's totally possible and and that is
why i have never
supported uh the bands i have never come
out
in in favor of banning a treatment that
might potentially work for one child
or be appropriate for one child i'm
totally open to the possibility
that it might be appropriate for one
child now the other question
how do we know we're not reverting to a
normal base rate how do we know this
isn't the rate
that we would all be at this isn't the
number of transgender people we would
always have seen
if not for all the stigma and harassment
that they experienced
and my answer to that is where are the
women
in their 40s 50s and 60s discovering
their transgender identity
now's their time where are they
why is it the same population that falls
for every other social contagion
teen girls with other mental health
comorbidities we should see this across
the whole population we don't
it's possible that it's somewhere in the
middle or even lower or at least higher
than it was
i guess what i'm saying like we're
probably higher than we would be now
but we do see people in their middle age
now who are transitioning
and for the first time feel comfortable
to do so
do you still think it's probably higher
than it used to be at least
so is this the normal rate that we would
the natural rate
that you we would see is that what
you're asking me
asking if you think the 2007 rate was
the normal rate
or if it falls somewhere in the middle i
don't know how i could possibly know
that
how do i know that you know what the
effect of culture is i mean i have a
someone i've become you know very
friendly with who was a lesbian for
years
um and now and transitioned because she
was
involved with a woman who was
uncomfortable being in a lesbian
relationship she transitioned in her
i think 40s to male and regretted that
so you know i you know and i'm not
saying that everyone would regret it you
know obviously we make all kinds of
decisions as adults i'm i'm completely
fine with adults making those decisions
but
if if you're asking me in the absence of
culture what would the
number of transgender people be i don't
know how i could have any idea
we have time for one more question to
the speakers left
i better make it a good one if i'm the
last one
abigail i discovered you through the
megan kelly podcast
which was excellent and one of the
things that drew me to you
is your kindness and your compassion
that there are people
who really do suffer from this and it's
a small number
but they deserve treatment and for those
who are struggling
we need to be kind in our conversation
about them so i appreciate that about
you
my first exposure to a trans child was
through a youth group
at church and the church completely bent
over
and supported this child and
really wrestled their parents to the
floor when they tried to object
so i would echo your sentiment that if
you are in a church
that is advocating this get out of that
church
my question my question is
kids you know teen years hardest years
of your life you're
changing the hormones are going crazy
but we know
girls develop around the age of 18 boys
frontal lobe not fully developed until
24.
so for those who are sorry guys
what do you advocate for someone who
really does need this treatment if we're
saying
delay delay let them grow up let them
fully develop
what is the age to have this
conversation it's a good question
i would say two things one to the point
about your church i mean the part of the
problem is
we have churches diagnosing kids right
we have pastors saying
oh it's a trans kid they they don't know
right there are there are little boys
who are effeminate and girls who are
a little more masculine and they would
just grow up and lead
you know healthy lives many of them
would become gay some of them wouldn't
but today they turn around and say oh
it's a trans kid
they've already decided what the
diagnosis is
what the identity is and started them
down a path
um that's you know that's very unusual
for a medical
condition um but there's something else
you asked the the second question was oh
what age
well here's what i would say i know a
lot of transgender adults
and the ones i've talked to are leading
good lives
and stable and good people and people
you would absolutely want as your
friends and neighbors
they have told me transitioning is
really hard
and they were really grateful for the
time they spent in therapy
making sure this would be right for them
they had to spend a certain
period of time living as the opposite
gender
trying to see if they could do this
because it's very stressful
okay today there's not no requirement
there's no requirement by that you get a
therapist note there's no requirement
for anything
i mean almost anything right so um
depend i mean the age of medical the
consent varies by state
okay so whatever whatever
people ultimately decide the age may be
and i'm not a doctor
but whatever people decide the
appropriate age may be
it certainly has to come with some sober
medical
oversight and right now we have
virtually none
what they have is medical encouragement
and celebration
please join me in thinking this is
[Applause]
schreier
you